pour finir c'est un objet magique
j'appelais punir les âmes un pur
d'échappement extrêmement cruelle je ne
peux pas révéler évidemment la teneur
ici à quel genre de match
[Musique]
regard du droit
et voilà maintenant un peu à gauche
ferme biologique du greffe et voilà
maintenant rester fermés et regarde
doucement à droite et à gauche
[Musique]
l'humain
à
[Musique]
black swan ouais
[Rires]
je
la talent et leur utilité
[Musique]
en seconde
c'est normal on n'est pas sûr c'est vrai
c'est ça n'inquiète pas de rancune
c'est vrai que tu goûtes acquis sans
rigoler euh je vous lis ouais je croyais
pas ça ouais j'étais persuadé du
contraire l or et caen où j'ai vues et
j'ai constaté ce truc là non eh ben je
me suis dit mais non battu de longs mois
le jeu
[Musique]
oh